preciou- [Voiceover] Hello
grammarians, hello Rosie!
- [Voiceover] Hi David!
- [Voiceover] How are you?
- [Voiceover] Good, how are you?
- [Voiceover] Good, today
we are going to talk about
run-ons and comma splices.
So a run-on sentence is what happens
when two independent
clauses are put together
in one sentence without any punctuation
or coordinating conjunctions
like and, but, or.
So Rosie what is a good
example of a run-on sentence?
- [Voiceover] We bought
nails we bought a hammer.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, so we
can see that this sentence
contains two individual,
independent clauses.
So we've got number one, we bought nails,
number two, we bought a hammer.
Now there are a couple of different ways
we could make this a legal sentence,
but right now as it stands
this is a run-on, right?
- [Voiceover] So there
are a couple of ways
we could fix this sentence.
One way would be just to
add a semicolon in there.
So you've got two independent clauses.
- [Voiceover] We bought nails, semicolon,
we bought a hammer.
- [Voiceover] Right.
Another way you could
do that would be to just
add a comma and then the conjunction and,
so you're connecting those two clauses.
- [Voiceover] So this is a
run-on sentence without this and,
and this comma, and it's called that
because it's sort of like
a runaway train, you know,
it doesn't have enough stoppage
in it is how I would put it.
So that's what a run-on sentence is,
and now I wanna talk about comma splicing.
And the word splice,
not a super-common term
if you are neither a
sailor or a film editor.
But splicing is a word
that originally meant
to take two ropes, untangle them,
and weave them back together.
It's a sailor's term
related to rope lines.
In our case for grammar, a splice,
a comma splice is an inappropriate joining
of two independent
clauses by using a comma.
So Rosie, this is Li'l
Tony, Crime Fighting Pony.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- [Voiceover] So for
example, in this sentence,
I love Li'l Tony 2: Pony Up 2 the Streets,
it's my favorite movie in
the Li'l Tony franchise,
a very fine series of non-existent films.
The problem with this
sentence is that right now
it's got this comma in the middle of it,
and this comma inappropriately joins
these two independent clauses.
Oh, and this whole time I forgot to say
two independent clauses
inappropriately joined by a comma.
So okay, so we've got
independent clause number one,
remember this thing could
stand on its own as a sentence,
I love the name of this movie.
I love Li'l Tony 2: Pony Up 2 the Streets.
That could be its own sentence on its own,
end it with a period, period.
It's my favorite movie in the
Li'l Tony franchise, period.
But we have these two
independent clauses, right?
We cannot join them with just a comma.
We could say I love Li'l Tony
2: Pony Up 2 the Streets,
comma, and it's my favorite
movie in the Li'l Tony franchise
or as we did in the previous example,
we could also throw in a semicolon,
which is I think what I would rather do.
I love Li'l Tony 2: Pony Up 2 the Streets;
semicolon, it's my favorite movie
in the Li'l Tony franchise.
And Rosie, you will notice
that I have underlined
these titles.
- [Voiceover] Oh yes.
- [Voiceover] Because these are the names
of published works, even
though we made them up.
- [Voiceover] Right, exactly.
- [Voiceover] But okay,
but for real I would love
to see like a Li'l Tony,
Crime Fighting Pony series.
- [Voiceover] Totally.
- [Voiceover] So to review,
when you're looking at a run-on,
you're looking at two independent
clauses that are together
in one sentence, that are
joined inappropriately
without punctuation or conjunctions.
So, we bought nails we bought a hammer.
There's not really a place to know
where the division between
clauses is in that,
and so the thing to do is
either to add some kind of,
is to add a comma and a conjunction,
or to combine them using a semicolon.
The same deal with a comma splice,
it's just that a comma splice is a run-on
that hasn't been fixed all the way.
- [Voiceover] Right,
the comma's being used
but we need some bigger
punctuation in place of the comma,
something like a semicolon,
in order to make a
distinction between those two
independent clauses.
- [Voiceover] So that is
how you identify and fix
run-ons and comma splices.
You can learn anything, David out.
- [Voiceover] Rosie out.